but I'll tell you what what I do think
in terms of of trans rights well first
of all so-called trans women in other
words biological men do have rights they
have men's rights and of course trans
people who live as the opposite sex and
I do know some and count some as my
friends do need to be able to live
dignified lives by which I mean if
they're passing through an airport with
a male passport but presenting as female
I do not wish those people to be
discriminated against or treated
um without dignity so we do need some
provision to protect those people living
as the opposite sex because that is how
they are living and that is a reality
but I think the idea that you can change
your legal sex and then all of a sudden
become recognized as women to all
intents and purposes is a danger to
women this isn't about keeping trans
women out of women's prisons Hospital
Wards or refuges it's about keeping men
out